so today we're going to talk about early
detection of silent liver cirrhosis now
here's the problem with cirrhosis which
is basically scar tissue of the liver
there is real no symptoms initially for
decades until the later stages so you
don't really always know that you have
cirrhosis however there is one symptom
that most people do experience and that
would be feeling sluggish and tired but
that could be coming from a lot of
different things you might not recognize
it so the two categories of cirrhosis
are compensated cirrhosis where the
body's compensating so really there's no
symptoms in this phase and then over
time you develop what's called
decompensated cirrhosis where you start
experiencing all these other symptoms so
these are some of the symptoms that you
experience when you have cirrhosis one
is spider angioma which is something on
your skin you have this little red dot
with these little red like spider webs
coming out from it xanthan Mo's which
are little cholesterol spots sometimes
you see them around the eyelids they're
yellow because the liver is not
functioning correctly
jaundice where your whites of your eyes
become yellow and also your skin starts
to become yellow that's liver damage
theater skin because you can't make
collagen anymore so you get this paper
like skin on the back of your hand and
you can see it pretty much all over and
then you have something called ascites
which is a fluid-filled sac around your
midsection it might look like it's a fat
gut but it's really fluid that's leaking
out from the liver creating like a
potbelly next one gynecomastia which is
basically breast tissue Club fingernails
okay so they're like a little square
little clubbed shape edema in the lower
leg you see this very very often with
liver damage and you press your finger
in the lower calf or the lower part of
the leg and you lead a little dent
okay that's edema swelling read palms
confusion bruising itchy skin itchy feet
cognitive issues so your focus your
memory your concentration just isn't
there so if you do research on cirrhosis
you see that people get a list for a
liver transplant
they're put on maybe some
supportive medication for other diseases
but they don't really tell you what to
do to prevent it or they don't give you
advice to what to do naturally but
there's a lot of confusion on this okay
that I want to sort out right now
because they'll say that cirrhosis is
associated with non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease and non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease is associated with
diabetes and metabolic syndrome and
obesity and so you just need to lose
weight and manage your diabetes symptoms
but they don't really sort out cause and
effect in what comes first second and
third well I'm just gonna explain right
now very simply it all starts with
something called insulin resistance okay
and that's created from alcohol or if
you're doing a non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease it can be created from junk food
a high carbohydrate diet sugar frequent
eating drugs legally or illegally or
even a virus could actually trigger
insulin resistance okay when you have
instant resistance you also have high
levels of insulin okay then you're going
to get inflammation so this condition
creates a lot of inflammation the
inflammation will also make the insulin
resistance worse then comes the fatty
liver 65 million Americans have a fatty
liver that's incredible that's a large
percentage so then after a fatty liver
you get scar tissue that replaces the
normal liver cell and that's called
cirrhosis so you get the scar tissue so
you have a combination of fatty liver
and inflamed liver that then becomes
filled with scar tissue and you lose
function so in summary insulin
resistance causes the liver to be fatty
okay insulin resistance is basically
what causes diabetes okay and diabetes
you're always gonna see insulin
resistance type 2 diabetes I'm talking
about that's the trigger of it because
it goes from insulin resistance creates
high insulin over a long period of time
then what happens you get a burnin
effects where the pancreas can't keep up
and then the blood sugar starts going
high that's called pre-diabetes
then it goes higher and then it's a
full-blown diabetes type 2 metabolic
syndrome is basically high cholesterol
blood sugar problems belly fat all
symptoms coming from insulin resistance
they kind of put it in this syndrome
like it's a it's like a disease by
itself when in fact it's just a bunch of
symptoms that are caused by this right
here okay obesity it's caused by instant
resistance high levels of insulin and
then cirrhosis is also caused by instant
resistance so this is really at the core
of this right here so if you start
having some of these symptoms I'm gonna
recommend that you start focusing on
this right here improve insulin
resistance and then see if these don't
improve as well I put a link down below
for more information on this and what
you need to do thanks for watching so I
want to know about what you think about
this video so please comment below and
tell me what you think